The following episode of How We Made Your Mother was recorded live on Instagram on January 28th, 2026.
以下这期《我们是如何创造你母亲的》于2026年1月28日在Instagram上进行了直播。
Hello, good people of Instagram.
大家好，Instagram的各位。
Welcome.
欢迎。
Craig Thomas.
克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）。
I'm here with Craig Thomas.
我和克雷格·托马斯在一起。
Craig Thomas, my dear friend, co-created the show, How I Met Your Mother with his friend and my friend Carter Bayes.
克雷格·托马斯，我亲爱的朋友，他和他的朋友、也是我的朋友卡特·贝斯（Carter Bayes）共同创作了《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
And we've been doing a podcast called How We Made Your Mother, where we go back through the show, been watching it with my wife, Jordana, who's never seen the show.
我们一直在做一个名为《我们是如何创造你母亲的》的播客，我们在节目中回看这部剧，和我从未看过这部剧的妻子乔丹娜（Jordana）一起观看。
I haven't seen it in many years either.
我也有好几年没看过它了。
I mean, Craig, it's been a couple years since you've seen it.
我是说，克雷格，你也有好几年没看过了。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Yeah.
是的。
So we're having a great time.
所以我们过得很开心。
We just finished watching season two.
我们刚刚看完第二季。
So we're what, 44 episodes into the 208?
所以我们算是什么进度？在总共208集里看了44集？
Crazy.
太疯狂了。
We made a little dent.
我们已经取得了一点进展。
It's not a huge dent, but we're getting there.
虽然进展不算很大，但我们正在努力。
We're looking to find people who don't know the podcast exists yet.
我们希望找到那些还不知道这个播客存在的人。
We're looking at we're going from more fans.
我们在寻找更多的粉丝。
Yeah.
是的。
If you are watching this podcast or listening rather, and you're enjoying it.
如果你正在观看这个播客，或者说收听这个播客，并且你很喜欢它。
Please recruit your family and your friends to join you in the joy of this.
请动员你的家人和朋友一起来享受这份乐趣。
And if you're just discovering us now, welcome.
如果你是现在才发现我们，欢迎。
We're so happy to have you.
很高兴有你的加入。
Start from episode one.
从第一集开始看起吧。
It's a great lesson.
这是一个很好的体验。
The episodes go by just like him and him itself.
每一集就像剧集本身一样过得飞快。
Go down easy.
轻松愉快。
But we are going deep into what made the show so special, what makes it so beloved after all these years.
但我们将深入探讨是什么让这部剧如此特别，是什么让它在这么多年后依然如此备受喜爱。
And Craig, now we're 44 episodes in, like, what has struck you overall about, like, the show we made together, especially the first two seasons?
克雷格，现在我们已经看了44集了，总的来说，关于我们一起创作的这部剧，尤其是前两季，有什么触动你的地方吗？
Like, what are your big thoughts right now?
比如，你现在有什么深刻的想法？
I really like it.
我真的很喜欢它。
Yeah, I really do.
是的，我真的很喜欢。
Yeah.
是的。
I find the best part of it is I feel not judgmental of it.
我发现最好的一点是，我对它不再带有评判心态了。
Like, I was so analytical and so lost in the weeds and the details and is the sound mix right.
以前我太爱分析了，深陷于琐事和细节中，比如声音混音对不对。
And when we would watch it with my wife on Monday nights when it and I'd sit there and go, you didn't laugh.
每逢周一晚上，当我跟我妻子一起看的时候，我就会坐在那儿说：“你刚才没笑。”
Did you not hear that word?
“你没听到那个词吗？”
Did we not mix?
“我们是不是没混音好？”
Was the music too hot against the dialogue?
“音乐是不是盖过对白了？”
And she'd be like, this is the worst.
而她会说：“这太糟糕了。”
Can I wash this without you from now on?
“以后没有你，我能自己看吗？”
And I was so like so intense about every little thing.
我对每一件小事都太紧张了。
And then now it's so great to just let it wash over me.
而现在，这种任由它洗刷我的感觉太棒了。
I watched it and I just enjoy it.
我看着它，只是单纯地享受。
It almost took 20 years to be able to watch it without that kind of neurotic thing.
差不多花了20年时间，我才能够以这种没有神经质的状态来观看它。
But you know what's funny?
但你知道有趣的是什么吗？
I did the same thing, but mostly around my own performance or whether that joke didn't work or like I should have done this, I can't tell you what any of those things were that I was worried about.
我也做过同样的事，但主要集中在自己的表现上，或者那个笑话有没有效果，或者我当时应该这么做——我简直说不出那些我曾经担心的事到底是什么。
Right, I'm not a thing at all.
对啊，根本没有一件事是值得的。
What was I so, I don't know what was I so excited about?
我当时到底在——我不知道我当时在兴奋什么？
Yeah, I was so proud of myself.
对啊，我当时对自己要求太高了。
Yeah, this is a great lesson.
是的，这是一个很好的教训。
Please take this lesson from us, good people of Instagram and this podcast.
Instagram和这个播客的各位好朋友们，请从我们这里吸取这个教训吧。
Be generous to yourself.
对自己大度一点。
If you're basically doing a good job, be like, I'm doing okay here.
如果你基本上做得不错，那就对自己说：“我在这里表现得还行。”
Although maybe the lesson is you gotta get some years under your belt before you can learn to do that.
不过也许这个教训是：你必须经历一些年头的磨砺，才能学会做到这一点。
Yes, you know, I do think that age confers, if you age with some grace, it confers a more forgiveness both for yourself and for other people, you know, that you realize, by the time you're our age, 50, 51, you realize you're just a bundle of flaws, you know, you're just like, you're never gonna, Oh yes.
是的，你知道，我确实认为随着年龄的增长，如果你优雅地老去，它会赋予你更多的宽容，无论是对你自己还是对其他人，你知道的，等到你到了我们这个年纪——50岁、51岁，你就会意识到你只是一堆缺点，你知道的，你就像——你永远不会——哦，是的。
The perfection that you chased in your 20s is not attainable and you have some acceptance of that.
你在20岁时追求的完美是无法达到的，你对此有了一定的接受度。
So we're really happy to be able to revisit the show and almost like talk to our younger selves, much like, you know, the older narrator character.
所以我们非常高兴能重新回顾这部剧，几乎就像是在和年轻时的自己对话，就像剧中的老年旁白角色一样。
We are featured head, that's the way.
我们是主角，就是这样。
It's nice to be able to talk to your past self and say, kid, you did okay.
能够和过去的自己对话，并说“孩子，你干得不错”，这种感觉真好。
You know, you did a really good job.
你知道，你真的干得很棒。
So we're really happy you're here.
所以我们非常高兴你能来到这里。
Thanks for joining us tonight.
谢谢你今晚加入我们。
You can see the blue French horn, behind me that's the actual blue French horn.
你可以看到我身后的蓝色法国号，那是真正的蓝色法国号。
Please do not break into my home steal that.
请千万不要私闯民宅去偷它。
No, this isn't even my half.
不，这甚至都不是我的那一半。
No, I'm kidding.
不，我开玩笑的。
But yeah, we're really happy you're here.
不过是的，很高兴你能来。
We're gonna try to answer a bunch of your bunch of your questions.
我们打算试着回答你们的一些问题。
Alec though, our producer, Alec Lev, a long time associated with how I met my mother for years.
不过我们的制作人亚历克（Alec）——亚历克·莱夫（Alec Lev），多年来一直与《老爸老妈浪漫史》共事。
He was the digital content creator and he ran he hosted the podcast that we did for a long time.
他曾是数字内容创作者，并且主持了我们做了很长时间的播客。
And Alec is now our producer.
现在亚历克是我们的制作人。
So we're always happy to see him and he will referee.
所以我们总是很高兴见到他，他将担任裁判。
He will keep this thing civilized.
他会维持这里的秩序。
What do you got for us, Alec?
亚历克，你给我们准备了什么？
The most important thing I have in high now, everyone, is Josh, can you make sure to plug in your iPhone?
各位，我现在要说的最重要的事情是，乔希，你能确保把你的iPhone插上电吗？
I'm getting a message that your iPhone is running out of power.
我收到一条消息，说你的iPhone电量快耗尽了。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
So you just do that where we talk.
所以你边聊边弄就行。
Where is it at?
电量还剩多少？
Instagram.
Instagram。
Instagram。Instagram。
Let's see how I do that.
看看我是怎么弄的。
Yeah, Josh is going to work on that.
好的，乔希会去处理那个。
He's got about 20% battery left.
他的电池电量还剩大约20%。
All right, all right, hold on.
好吧，好吧，等等。
We might be able to get through, it's 20%, though, right?
我们也许能撑过去，不过还剩20%对吧？
I could say a couple of things here.
我可以在这里说几件事。
First of all, is Alex Lourdes, high out there, she asks, is this live or pre-recorded?
首先，亚历克·洛德斯（Alex Lourdes）在外面举手吗？她问，这是直播还是预录的？
I think this is for Alex.
我想这是针对亚历克的。
I think we're answering this really well right now.
我觉得我们现在这个问题回答得很好。
Is this live?
这是直播吗？
And Josh isn't there right now?
而乔希现在不在那儿？
I think you know it's live.
我想你知道这是直播。
That's not a creative choice for me.
这对我来说不是什么创作选择。
I'm just going to also shout out some country.
我还要大声向一些国家打招呼。
Everyone here who is putting in their country's flags, it looks great.
这里每个打出自己国家国旗的人，看起来都很棒。
but I don't know what the flags represent for all of them.
但我不知道这些国旗分别代表什么。
So if you could type out your country, we'd love to read out where everyone is coming from.
所以如果你能打出你的国家，我们很乐意宣读大家都是从哪里来的。
I'm just gonna read a few here.
我随便读几个。
We've got El Salvador and Iran, China, Canada, Brazil, Peru, Mexico, Portugal, Turkey, Argentina, and Spain.
我们有萨尔瓦多、伊朗、中国、加拿大、巴西、秘鲁、墨西哥、葡萄牙、土耳其、阿根廷和西班牙。
Absolutely incredible.
简直不可思议。
Hey, everybody.
大家好。
Thank you for joining us.
感谢你们加入我们。
Thank you for watching how much your mother all around the world.
感谢全世界各地的观众收看《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
This is such an international show, this show.
这是一个非常国际化的节目，这个节目。
It's gone so international.
已经变得非常国际化了。
We hear from people all over the place.
我们听到了来自世界各地人们的声音。
It's such an honor and we're hearing that on the pod a lot.
这真的是一种荣幸，我们在播客里经常听到这样的声音。
A lot of people that write in or send its voice messages, they're from really unexpected to cool places and it blows our minds every time.
许多写信或发语音留言的人，都来自意想不到且很酷的地方，每次都让我们大开眼界。
It's so cool.
太酷了。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Absolutely.
确实如此。
Mr. Maseko 11 says, there's a podcast with a lot of question marks.
Maseko 11 先生说，这是一个有很多问号的播客。
See, this is the problem.
看吧，这就是问题所在。
You spread the word.
你得宣传一下。
We gotta spread the word, man.
我们得宣传一下，伙计。
That's right.
没错。
Flooky.shh says the same thing I didn't know it existed.
Flooky.shh 说得一样，我以前都不知道它的存在。
So we're doing this.
所以我们在做这个。
This is why we're doing this, is one of the reasons why we're doing this, but please, if you are, you're listening to this either right now, you're live with us right now, or it might be that you're listening to this as a podcast, because this is going to be in our podcast feed, in a couple of weeks.
这就是我们做这个的原因，也是我们做这个的原因之一，但是拜托，如果你现在正在听，现在正和我们一起进行直播，或者你可能是在作为播客收听，因为这将在几周后出现在我们的播客订阅源里。
Yeah, so if you're, by the way, we're having a really good comedy that happened where when Josh is making noise, it cuts to his shot, but it's just his empty frame of a fireplace and the blueprint's short and he's nowhere to be seen, and it's making me laugh every time, I'm sorry.
对，所以如果你……顺便说一句，发生了一件很好笑的事，当乔斯发出声音时，镜头切换到他那里，但那只是壁炉的空镜头，蓝图很短，根本看不到他的人，每次都逗得我哈哈大笑，对不起。
This isn't gonna be great audio content.
这可不是什么绝佳的音频内容。
Here he is, we got him.
他在这儿，我们找到他了。
That's all right.
没关系。
Here he is.
他在这儿呢。
Is that charging?
在充电吗？
Yes.
是的。
As long as it's charging, it's good.
只要在充电就行。
Lish defense.
防卫。
Eagle had fans spying on your phone charge.
伊格尔有粉丝在窥探你的手机充电情况。
Wait, was that you or Alec?
等等，那是你还是亚历克？
That was a fan, a fan wrote it in, right?
那是粉丝，有粉丝写信过来的吧？
Alec?
亚历克？
No?
没有吗？
No, no, no, it was, no, it was Riverside.
不，不，不，那是，不，那是 Riverside。
Riverside on New Jersey.
新泽西州的 Riverside。
It was Riverside, okay, I thought a fan could see it.
是 Riverside，好吧，我还以为粉丝能看到呢。
I can see it.
我能看到。
Yeah.
对。
Lish, Lish dish 13 says this podcast to change my relationship with the show in the best way possible.
Lish dish 13 说，这个播客以最好的方式改变了我对这部剧的看法。
And then, um, hmm, Laysmark solely says, is there a podcast where you can comment on the show?
然后，嗯，hmm，Laysmark solely 说，有没有一个可以对节目发表评论的播客？
Well, um, Josh, why don't you explain to people how they can comment on the, on the podcast, where they can write into us?
好吧，嗯，乔斯，你为什么不向大家解释一下他们怎么在播客上评论，以及怎么写信给我们呢？
Yeah, so if you listen to the show, uh, one of the first, uh, the things you'll hear, uh, is we often will play a voice note or a voice memo from, uh, a fan from all over the world.
好的，如果你收听这个节目，嗯，你会听到的第一批事情之一，就是我们经常会播放来自世界各地粉丝的语音留言或语音备忘录。
we've heard from people all over the world.
我们听到了来自世界各地人们的声音。
And the prompt is essentially, what is how I met your mother mean to you?
而提示基本上是，《老爸老妈浪漫史》对你意味着什么？
Just tell us what the show means to you.
只需告诉我们这部剧对你意味着什么。
And we've gotten the most extraordinary, beautiful, heartfelt, amazing letters.
我们收到了非常非凡、美丽、真挚、惊艳的信件。
So that's a voice memo.
所以那是语音备忘录。
If you want us to potentially play your voice memo on air, I'll tell you how in one second, but you can also write us a letter, good old fashioned email.
如果你希望我们在节目中播放你的语音备忘录，我一会儿告诉你怎么做，但你也可以给我们写信，通过老式的电子邮件。
So go to how we made your mother.com or HWMYM.com, go to contact and just follow the instructions.
所以访问 how we made your mother.com 或 HWMYM.com，点击联系我们，然后按照说明操作。
It should be pretty self-explanatory.
这应该是不言自明的。
But we'd love to hear from you.
但我们很想听到你的声音。
So, yeah, send us that.
所以，是的，给我们发信息吧。
It's by far the best, our favorite part.
这绝对是最好、最让我们喜爱的一部分。
It's the best part of doing this.
这是做这件事最棒的部分。
It's hearing from the fans, and it's always a big part of every episode of the podcast.
那就是倾听粉丝的心声，这也一直是播客每期节目的重要组成部分。
So get involved, come listen, and yeah, join us there.
所以参与进来，来收听吧，是的，加入我们。
What else have we got, Alec?
我们还有什么，亚历克？
How do we answer questions now?
我们现在怎么回答问题？
Well, we could do that.
嗯，我们可以这么做。
First of all, by the way, let's just have a conversation with our friend here, Alex Lourdes, who was wondering if this was live, who says the intro was so smooth, I thought it was pre-recorded.
首先，顺便说一句，让我们先和我们的朋友亚历克斯·劳尔德斯（Alex Lourdes）聊聊，他刚刚还在纳闷这到底是不是直播，他说开场太流畅了，他还以为是录播呢。
So, right, probably right up until the...
所以，对吧，大概直到……
It was really, it fooled me until you guys shot the bed with the battery tray.
真的很厉害，在你们因为电池问题搞砸之前，我都被骗了。
When it would be amazing if it was pre-recorded, but we were such geniuses that we built in the iPhone debacle.
如果这是录播就太棒了，而我们又是如此天才，竟然把 iPhone 的闹剧给设计进去了。
Yeah.
对。
On the block.
在区里。
Okay, so here's just a lovely question here from I Am Nina Now says from Buenos Aires, although not exactly the question, I want to thank Josh for writing kind over matter on a piece of paper a few years ago so I could get it tattooed.
好的，这里有一个来自“我是现在的妮娜”的可爱问题，她说来自布宜诺斯艾利斯，虽然不完全是这个问题，但我要感谢乔斯几年前在一张纸上写下“随缘善念”（kind over matter），好让我能把它纹在身上。
Wow, was that in, I wonder if it was in Buenos Aires when Ben Lee and I played there in like maybe 2017?
哇，那是，我不知道是不是在布宜诺斯艾利斯，当时本·李和我大概在 2017 年在那里演出？
Let us know, yeah, yeah, yeah.
让我们知道，对，对，对。
That's awesome, we'd love to see the tattoo.
太棒了，我们很想看看这个纹身。
Yeah, a lot of tattoos, right Craig?
对，有很多纹身，对吧，克雷格？
We've seen so many of how I met your mother-related tattoos.
我们见过太多与《老爸老妈浪漫史》相关的纹身了。
It's crazy.
太疯狂了。
That wasn't exactly that instance.
那倒不完全是那个情况。
That was something Josh did that was awesome.
那是乔斯做过的一件很棒的事。
But him and fans are sending us some pretty.
但他和粉丝们给我们发了一些相当……
A lot of yellow umbrella.
有很多黄色雨伞。
Lou French horn speaking of quotes from the show.
说到剧中的台词，还有法国号。
All kinds of stuff.
各种各样的东西。
What an honor for things from the show to be on somebody's body.
剧中物品能出现在别人的身体上，是多么荣幸的一件事。
That's a fan.
那才是粉丝。
That's a real fan.
那才是真正的粉丝。
And I wrote you this little ditty to send you in New York City.
我为你写了这首小曲，送给远在纽约的你。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈德曼，是“超级修复”（Hyper-Fixed）播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会接受听众的求助并努力为他们解决问题。
Problems like, I'm 30, and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如这样的问题：我 30 岁了，但害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么倒车时我无法调节车载音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们也解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果你遇到了问题，我们不仅会帮你解决，还会揭示导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这就是来自 Radiotopia 的“超级修复”播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts, or at hyperfixedpod.com.
你可以在各大播客平台或访问 hyperfixedpod.com 找到它。
And now, back to the show.
现在，让我们回到节目中。
Okay, I'm gonna just start off with just a really big question here, because it's a lovely one.
好的，我打算以一个非常重磅的问题开始，因为这是一个很可爱的问题。
It might take some time for you guys to think about, or you might have several answers to, so let's just go for it.
你们可能需要花点时间思考，或者你们有多个答案，所以我们这就开始吧。
This actually comes to us from Instagram.
这个问题实际上来自我们的 Instagram。
Benny Belive says, it would be so interesting to know what was your favorite day on set and why.
Benny Belive 说，真想知道你们在片场的哪一天最难忘，为什么。
Is there a special day where everyone just had the best work day?
有没有那么一天，每个人都度过了最棒的工作日？
Or would you say that every day of shooting was special in its own way?
或者你会说，每天的拍摄都有它独特而特殊的地方？
Thank you so much for entertainment over all these years.
非常感谢你们这么多年来带给我们的欢乐。
The series makes me smile.
这部剧总是能让我会心一笑。
I can't, it's so cool that you're doing this here in 2026.
我真是没想到，你们竟然能在2026年在这里做这件事，太酷了。
So, if you're just thinking back, especially to these first two seasons, are there days that to just pop into your mind as being memorable for one reason or another.
所以，如果你回想过去，尤其是前两季的时候，有没有哪几天，因为这样或那样的原因，突然蹦进你的脑海，让你觉得印象深刻？
Yeah, that's a great question.
对，这是一个很好的问题。
I think that I want to answer the second part of what he asked though about was every day the best.
不过我觉得我想回答他问的第二部分，关于是不是每天都是最好的一天。
And I will say no to that.
我要说不是。
And that's just, that's just because we did nine years.
这只是因为我们拍了九年。
And if you take a decade of your life, no matter where you are, how your work it would, like you're gonna have good days and you're gonna have not so good days, but you gotta show up at the office anyway, you know?
如果你把十年的生命投入其中，无论你在哪里，无论你的工作是什么，你都会有状态好的日子，也会有状态不那么好的日子，但你还是得去办公室上班，对吧？
So you just have to bring yourself wherever you are.
所以无论你在哪，你都得打起精神来。
I think when the cameras rolled, we all tried to drink the fake beer and eat the Chex mix and do our jobs and sell the jokes and authentically play our parts.
我觉得当镜头开机时，我们都努力喝着假啤酒，吃着混合零食，做好本职工作，把笑话包袱抖响，真情实感地扮演好我们的角色。
But some days were hard on set and other days, I will say it wasn't all like the blooper reel, although every moment from the Bulletproof reel actually happened and was as funny and joyful as it looked, you know?
但有些天在片场确实很难熬，而另一些天……我得说，并不完全像花絮里那样轻松，尽管爆笑花絮里的每一个瞬间都是真实发生的，而且和看起来一样有趣、欢乐，对吧？
So I think that when I think of like happy moments on set, for some reason, this always stays with me.
所以我想，当我回想起片场那些快乐的时刻时，出于某种原因，这个画面一直留在我心中。
And I think I talked about this once on the podcast.
我想我曾在播客里提到过一次。
We would often do like early morning or breakfast scenes, you know, Marshall, Lilly, and Ted in sweatpants having breakfast, you know?
我们经常要拍一些清晨或吃早餐的戏，你知道的，马修、莉莉和泰德穿着运动裤吃早餐，懂吗？
We just, what happened?
我们刚刚……怎么了？
Josh, can you just say that last thing one more time?
乔希，你能把刚才那句最后的话再说一遍吗？
we just lost your last two sentences there.
我们刚刚没听清你最后两句话。
Oh, okay.
哦，好吧。
Well, when I think about happy moments on set, is that what you were talking about?
嗯，当我想到片场那些快乐的时刻时，你是说那个吗？
Yeah.
对。
When I think about happy moments on set, we often, I think I talked about this on the podcast at one point, but Jason and Ali and myself, as Ted Marshall and Lily, we would often do like breakfast scenes.
当我想到片场那些快乐的时刻时，我们经常——我想我之前在播客里也提到过——杰森、艾莉和我，作为泰德、马修和莉莉，我们经常拍那种早餐的戏。
And for some reason, they would sometimes, Mike Shea, the way he structured them, the breakfast or early morning scenes would often be the first scenes of the day.
而且不知为什么，迈克·谢（Mike Shea）对它们的结构安排，早餐或清晨的戏往往会是一天中的第一场戏。
So you drive to the Fox lot in Los Angeles, you'd get out of your car, you'd go through hair and makeup, and you'd go into your dressing room and you had to change into like a t-shirt and sweatpants.
所以你开车去洛杉矶的福克斯片场，下车，做发型和化妆，走进化妆间，然后你得换上一件T恤和运动裤。
And then you get on set and Dave Baker, the props guy goes, what cereal do you want?
接着你来到片场，道具师戴夫·贝克（Dave Baker）就会问：“你想吃什么麦片？”
What do you want in your coffee?
“你的咖啡里要加什么？”
And then you would just sit there and have breakfast and drink coffee and make each other laugh.
然后你就在那里吃早餐、喝咖啡，逗彼此笑。
And it was just like, there were those moments where you're like, I can't believe I'm getting paid for that.
那种感觉就像是，有时候你会想：我简直不敢相信自己居然能因为这而拿到报酬。
Like, I have someone's gonna come and discover that this is like too fun, like too much fun.
就像，会有什么人来发现这一切简直太有趣了，乐趣过头了。
It's too, it was just a blast, you know, to have that be your job, you know?
太棒了，把这当成你的工作，真的是一种享受，你知道吗？
And yeah, yeah.
对，对。
Yeah, I would just add on to that too and say that there would just be certain moments every so often, because you lose, it's what Josh is saying, it's your job.
对，我还要补充一点，就是每隔一段时间就会出现某些特定时刻，因为你渐渐习惯了，正如乔希所说，这就是你的工作。
It's every day you start taking it for granted.
每天你都开始把它视为理所当然。
It doesn't feel like showbiz every day or magical, magical every second.
它并不总是像什么好莱坞秀场，也不是每分每秒都那么神奇。
But every now and again, there'd be some moment where I'd just take a half step back and I'd look at Josh Radner reading dialogue that I wrote or that Carter wrote or that we all fashioned together on the writers from the day before.
但偶尔会有那么一个瞬间，我会稍微退后半步，看着乔希·拉德纳（Josh Radnor）念着我写的台词，或者卡特写的台词，又或者是我们前一天在编剧室里一起琢磨出来的台词。
Josh and Kobe acting in a scene together and then they kind of zoom out and you go, and there's Pam Fryman directing it and there's our entire crew and there's Dave Baker with the Lucky Charms for whoever ordered Lucky Charms and whatever it was.
看着乔希和科比在一场戏里搭戏，然后脑海里画面拉远，你会感叹，帕姆·弗莱曼（Pam Fryman）正在导演这场戏，我们的整个剧组都在，还有带着幸运麦片（Lucky Charms）的戴夫·贝克，给任何点名要幸运麦片的人准备着，不管是谁。
And like every now and again, I'd sort of like grasp the totality of it and just go like, this is everyone's here on the same mission, right?
然后偶尔，我就会有一种对全局的领悟，心里就会想：大家来这里都是为了同一个目标，对吧？
We all, we came up with this thing and we said, hey everybody, would you come into our little universe and yes and it and kind of play with us?
我们想出了这个点子，然后对大家说：“嘿，各位，你们愿意进入我们的小宇宙，顺着我们的设定，跟我们一起玩吗？”
Like two kids playing together.
就像两个小孩在一起玩过家家一样。
I think that's the spirit of like, we're gonna play, we're gonna get our Star Wars guys, we're gonna play.
我觉得这就是那种精神：我们要去玩，我们要拿出星球大战的玩偶，我们要开始玩了。
And every now and again, it would occur to me, like you just said, Josh, like, how is this our job?
偶尔我会有这种感觉，就像你刚才说的，乔希：“这怎么能是我们的工作呢？”
How are we able to come do this?
我们怎么能来做这个？
How is everybody here agreeing this universe exists and making it up together?
为什么大家都会同意这个宇宙的存在，并一起把它编造出来？
And every now and again, that feeling would hit me and it was the greatest feeling.
偶尔这种感觉会涌上心头，那是最美妙的感觉。
I felt that when I directed both movies I wrote, I was like, I dreamt this scene up in a coffee shop.
当我导演自己写的那两部电影时，我也有过这种感觉，我当时想：“我在一家咖啡馆里梦想出了这个场景。”
Yeah.
对。
This started in my imagination and now all these people are bringing it to life.
这一切始于我的想象，现在所有这些人都在把它变成现实。
And I can't believe I'm looking through a camera and seeing kind of what I dreamt up, but better.
我简直不敢相信我正透过摄像机镜头，看着我曾经梦想中的画面，甚至比我想象的还要好。
Better.
还要好。
Yeah, that's it.
对，就是这样。
That's it, it's the humbling feeling of how much better it is than you could have ever dreamt it to be.
就是这样，那种感觉会让你感到谦卑，因为它比你曾经梦想过的还要好得多。
It feels, that's the magic, that's the magical piece.
那种感觉，这就是魔法，这就是神奇的部分。
I will say also, there's something called, I think it's called the hedonic treadmill.
我还想说，有个概念，我想它叫“享乐适应”（hedonic treadmill）。
Have you ever heard of that phrase?
你听说过这个词吗？
It's basically like the things you dream about and it's basically how quickly we metabolize our good fortune that the thing you wanted five years ago, you have it and you're suddenly like, the couches here are terrible.
它基本上是指，那些你梦寐以求的东西……也就是我们习惯好运的速度有多快：你五年前想要的东西，现在你得到了，而你突然就会开始挑剔：“这里的沙发太糟糕了。”
Like you just immediately go back to your same level of dissatisfaction and looking forward to the next thing.
就像你立刻又回到了原来的不满水平，然后开始期待下一件东西。
And you know, I knew that this was a great gig and I knew that the writing was really sharp and I knew the cast was jelling and I knew we were firing all cylinders.
你知道的，我知道这是一个很棒的工作，我知道剧本非常犀利，我知道演员们相处融洽，我也知道我们火力全开。
And still, you have days where you're like, like you're dragging your feet, you're not as inspired.
即便如此，你还是会有状态不佳的日子，比如你拖着沉重的脚步，灵感不那么迸发。
One thing that would happen is, when people would come and visit, like if out of town, like some of my parents would drop by set or family friends or whatever who wanted to come by.
但有件事经常发生，那就是当有人来探班的时候，比如从外地来的人，我的父母或者亲友什么的顺道来看看。
There was something about having the external, like when someone from Ohio comes to visit.
有些时候，当有了外部视角——比如当一个来自俄亥俄州的人来参观时。
Yes, and you see it through their eyes.
没错，你会通过他们的眼睛来看待这一切。
You see it through their eyes.
你通过他们的眼睛去审视。
Those days were actually really interesting to me because I was like, oh, this is a cool job.
那些天对其实我来说真的很有趣，因为我会想：哦，这确实是一份很酷的工作。
Like this is really interesting fun.
这真的是一项非常有趣好玩的工作。
Yeah.
对。
But you just, it's not that you take it for granted.
但这只是……并不是说你把它当成理所当然。
It just, the repetition, it just becomes something.
只是日复一日的重复，它最终变成了一种……
just becomes your life.
最终变成了你的生活。
It's your daily life, it's your normal.
这是你的日常生活，这是你的常态。
And then every now and again, you're reminded, this is not normal in the best way possible.
然后偶尔，你会得到提醒：这可不是什么常态，这是最棒的那种不寻常。
This is not normal.
这不是常态。
This is really extraordinary what's happening here.
这里正在发生的事情真的是非同寻常。
And it's just human nature.
这只是人之常情。
You do, you get used to stuff, you don't always appreciate the magic.
你确实会习惯一些事情，你并不总是能感激这份神奇。
I'm coming, I'm like, parenthood is clicking into my brain here a little bit, right?
我就要说……这让我的脑海里联想到了一点育儿的经验，对吧？
You have these amazing little humans and you sort of, in between those moments of like, wonder and appreciation, you're doing the grunt work of parenting and you're sometimes losing the magic of like what that is and then like something hits you and you're like, fuck, wait, this is the greatest thing in the world.
你拥有了这些可爱的小生命，在那些充满惊叹和感激的时刻之间，你正在做着养育孩子的繁重杂务，有时你甚至会忘记那种奇妙的感觉是什么，然后突然间有什么击中了你，你会想：“操，等等，这是世界上最棒的事情。”
And it's akin to that.
这跟那种感觉很像。
And it's almost like the grunt work is part of the magic because without that, it's like it doesn't, you know, if you just went.
而且可以说，这种繁重的杂务正是魔法的一部分，因为如果没有这个，它就像是……你知道的，如果你只是……
You're earning the magic with the grunt work.
你用这些繁重的工作赢得了这份魔力。
If you just went from triumph to triumph, let's say you were just like an actor that was just triumphant and you just won every award, Like, there would be something you would hate about that, eventually.
如果你只是从一个胜利走向另一个胜利，比如说你是一个一路高歌猛进、赢得所有奖项的演员，那么到最后，你一定会讨厌那种生活的。
Yeah, oh yeah.
对，哦，是的。
You'd be like, there's no, where's the struggle, where's the ascent, where's the resilience that I'm having to find, you know?
你会觉得：没有挑战，奋斗在哪里，攀登在哪里，我需要去寻找的韧性在哪里，你知道吗？
Yeah.
对。
It's a hard thing because it's hard to struggle, but without struggle, who are we?
这是一件艰难的事，因为挣扎很难，但如果没有挣扎，我们又是谁？
We don't get forged, you know?
我们无法被塑造，你知道吗？
Yeah, I think that's right.
对，我觉得确实如此。
And I think we also made it hard on ourselves in a good way on how Mitch and Mother, because he didn't do the same episode every week.
而且我觉得我们在《老爸老妈浪漫史》中也以一种好的方式给自己制造了难度，因为我们每周拍的不是同一集。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
It wasn't the cookie cutter.
它不是那种千篇一律的模式。
Like here is basically what a himium episode is.
比如“老爸老妈浪漫史”的一集差不多就是这样。
We're going to do this 200 times more or less.
我们要把这种模式再重复200次，差不多吧。
We've really tried it.
我们真的尝试过了。
We're always challenging yourself and almost like challenging every department.
我们总是在挑战自己，几乎是在挑战每一个部门。
Absolutely.
绝对是的。
The whole thing was challenged accepted and everyone accepted it and that's the magic.
整部剧的主旨就是“接受挑战”，每个人也都接受了，这就是魔法所在。
We just talked about something borrowed, something blue, which is the one where Marshall shaved the landing strip in his head at the before the wedding, something borrowed.
我们刚才谈到了《借来的东西》（Something Borrowed），《蓝色诉求》（Something Blue），就是马修在婚礼前把头剃成飞机头的那一集……那是《借来的东西》。
So it's some, it's the finale, right?
所以那是，那是季终集，对吧？
This season finale season.
这一季的季终集。
I thought it was something borrowed, though.
不过我原以为那是《借来的东西》。
Oh, something borrowed, right, yeah, isn't it?
哦，借来的东西，对吧，是的，是这样吗？
Sorry, you're absolutely right.
抱歉，你完全说得对。
Yeah, so something borrowed was...
对，所以借来的东西是……
Second of all.
第二点。
Jason gets the cool guy tips, he freaks out, and he takes the razor and he shaves that reverse mohawk in his head.
杰森得到了酷哥的建议，他吓坏了，然后他拿起剃须刀，在头上剃了个倒莫霍克发型。
Yeah.
对。
And I said to Craig, I was like, if you're in the hair department reading the script, you're like, oh shit.
我对克雷格说，我说，如果你在发型部门读剧本，你肯定会想，哦操。
Like, we have to get frosted tips on Jason's hair somehow, and then we have to create an effect where he takes a razor.
就像，我们得想办法在杰森的头发上弄出挑染效果，然后我们还得创造一个他拿起剃须刀的效果。
Jase is ahead.
杰斯先上了。
Yeah.
对。
Like, I mean, it was a huge ask of the makeup, I mean, that shot department.
我是说，这对化妆，我是说对那个拍摄部门来说是个巨大的要求。
There should have been a special Emmy just for that shot, how well that went.
那个镜头应该专门得个艾美奖，拍得太好了。
On the first try.
一次就过。
We only did one take of it.
我们只拍了一条。
And you can see me laughing for reals.
你可以看到我是真的在笑。
Because it was a miracle.
因为那是个奇迹。
We all be knew we had witnessed a miracle.
我们都知道我们见证了一个奇迹。
Yeah.
对。
What else?
还有呢？
Paulo, I'd say, just as, hi Josh, hope you remember your concert in Sao Paulo, Brazil.
保罗，我想说，作为问候，嗨，乔什，希望你还记得你在巴西圣保罗的演唱会。
I gave you a flag with your names.
我送了你一面写着你们名字的旗帜。
That's from Paulo.
那是保罗发来的。
I sure do remember that because 1200 people came and saw us in Sao Paulo and it was such a fun night.
我当然记得，因为当时有1200人来圣保罗看我们演出，那真是个非常快乐的夜晚。
So shout out to all the Brazilians.
所以向所有的巴西人喊话。
We had such a, Ben and I went there.
我们有——我和本去过那儿。
We had five shows in Brazil, and yeah, I'd love to come back.
我们在巴西有五场演出，对，我很想再去。
I very much remember that night.
我非常清楚地记得那个夜晚。
Now we're back, our old friend, Work Work Eliza, is back saying that she's the one named after your grandmother Rose, but again, with no details.
现在我们回来了，我们的老朋友“工作工作伊莉莎”又回来了，说她是那个以你的祖母罗斯的名字命名的人，但同样没有给出细节。
So Work Work Eliza, while you're here, just are you saying that you are, have the same name as both of Josh's grandmothers?
所以“工作工作伊莉莎”，趁你在这儿，你是在说你和乔什的两位祖母名字都一样吗？
And the grandmother was not named Eliza.
而且祖母的名字不叫伊莉莎。
I just...
我只是……
Right, right.
对，对。
Well, the screen name is Work Work Eliza, but we understand that it's Rose, but Work Work Eliza Rose, if you could just expand a little, we are curious, if you were actually named after the person, or you just happen to have the same name, okay.
好吧，网名是“工作工作伊莉莎”，但我们知道那是罗斯，不过“工作工作伊莉莎·罗斯”，如果你能稍微展开说说，我们很好奇，你究竟是不是按那个人的名字取名的，还是纯粹刚好同名，好吧。
Let's go with this one, people, you know what?
我们就聊这个吧，各位，你知道吗？
My friends, people love the deleted scenes, and Isaac Cardoza has a question, so many people ask, what are your favorite deleted scenes?
我的朋友们，大家都很喜欢被删减的片段，伊萨克·卡多扎有个问题，很多人都在问，你们最喜欢的被删减片段是什么？
What are some of your favorite bloopers that you remember, either from the moment or from actually going back to it.
你们还记得哪些最喜欢的爆笑NG镜头，不管是当时发生的还是后来回看时发现的。
I'm curious, Josh, I don't totally, do you remember specific moments where you really lost your shit or you did something insane happen?
我很想知道，乔什，我不太确定，你还记得有哪些特定时刻，你真的是笑到崩溃或者发生了什么疯狂的事情吗？
What is that for you?
对你来说那是怎样的？
I remember Martin Short making me laugh quite a bit.
我记得马丁·肖特逗得我笑了不少次。
He's so funny.
他太搞笑了。
Well, bloopers are different than deleted scenes.
好吧，NG镜头和删减片段可不一样。
Right, is it a blooper question?
对，这是一个关于NG的问题吗？
Something like that.
差不多吧。
That's true, I'm sorry.
也对，不好意思。
This one does say deleted scenes.
这个确实写的是删减片段。
Interesting, yeah.
有意思，对。
I mean, there's a scene that I think is on the DVDs, but it was cut from the finale, me and Kobe, that scene in the diner, which I thought was quite important, actually.
我是说，有一个场景我想应该是收录在DVD里的，但它从大结局里被剪掉了，我和科比的，我们在小餐馆里的那个场景，其实我觉得挺重要的。
Yeah, I missed that scene, and I missed that scene.
对，我也怀念那个场景，我也怀念那个场景。
That was the finale game in two hours.
那是大结局倒计时两小时。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
That was the heart-breaker for me.
那对我来说是个心碎的时刻。
Yeah, but you can track that scene down.
对，不过你可以把那个场景找出来。
It might be on YouTube.
可能在YouTube上能找到。
It is, yeah, it's very easy to get.
确实在，对，很容易就能找到。
It's on YouTube, for sure, and it was on those DVDs, And yeah, look it up.
YouTube上绝对有，而且那些DVD里也有，是的，去查查看吧。
That was a really interesting scene in the finale that we just.
大结局里那段真的很有意思，我们只是……
And ends with the salute.
并且以一个敬礼结束。
For whatever reason.
不管出于什么原因。
I didn't get in.
没能放进去。
Yeah, I know.
对，我知道。
That was a good scene.
那是个好场景。
That should have been in there maybe.
也许本该放进去的。
Yeah.
对。
To make the argument.
可以争论一番。
Oh well.
算了吧。
Lishdish13, by the way, wants to add, Josh, I was your merch girl in Sacramento at your show.
顺便说一句，Lishdish13想补充说，乔什，我在萨克拉门托你的演出现场卖过你的周边。
Oh.
哦。
Your music is still my current obsession.
你的音乐至今仍是我最大的痴迷。
Oh, that's so nice.
哦，太暖心了。
Thank you for doing that.
谢谢你做这些。
Thanks to all the people that worked merch on my tour.
谢谢所有在我的巡演上卖周边的工作人员。
Everyone was so kind and great.
每个人都非常友善和优秀。
And yeah.
还有，是的。
Thank you.
谢谢你们。
Alyssa speaks for many when she asks, what happened to Jordana's segment?
阿莉莎说出了很多人的心声，她问，乔达娜的环节怎么了？
We miss her.
我们想她。
Yeah, well, she's upstairs.
对，嗯，她在楼上。
All right, talk for no quiet, tell us what happened.
好吧，大声点别安静，告诉我们发生什么了。
Yeah, I mean, we announced this on a couple of podcasts ago, but we had a baby.
对，我是说，我们在前几期播客里宣布过这事，我们有孩子了。
My wife and I had a baby boy.
我和我妻子迎来了我们的宝贝儿子。
So if you didn't know this, parenting is a lot of work, and so we just decided to pause her segment for a little bit.
所以如果你还不知道的话，养育孩子是一件很繁重的工作，所以我们只是决定暂时把她的环节停播一段时间。
Well, I've been really gratified because we've heard so many people miss Jordana's segment, and she should be very flattered, and we should maybe be a little upset because people clearly like it better than us, you know, as flattered about bullshit.
好吧，我真的感到很欣慰，因为我们听到有这么多人怀念乔达娜的环节，她应该感到受宠若惊，而我们或许该有点不高兴，因为很显然大家比喜欢我们更喜欢她，你知道的，就当是虚惊一场的受宠若惊吧。
But I also like to remind people, I'm still getting questions and observations from a clinical psychologist, who never seen him or me or my mother, who also happened to me.
但我也喜欢提醒大家，我依然会收到来自一位临床心理学家的提问和观察，他从来没见过他、我和我母亲，而这也恰好发生在我身上。
It's a segment for one.
这首先是一个人的环节。
It's an audience.
这是一个观众。
It's an segment for one.
这是一个人的环节。
I'm sitting next to her on the couch.
我就坐在她身边的沙发上。
She makes great observations.
她观察得很到位。
And then I go do the podcast, and some of which they filter into my thinking, but I'm really, she's accepting these ideas into my head.
然后我去录播客，其中有些观点渗透到了我的思考中，但我真的，她是在把这些想法灌输进我的脑子里。
What if we discovered she was, at this moment, doing a competing IG live with way more people?
如果我们发现她此刻正在做一个观众多得多的竞争性IG直播会怎样？
You heard her upstairs, you're like, what, you go up there?
你听到她在楼上，你会想，什么，你上去了？
What are you doing?
你在干嘛？
Oh, this is awkward.
哦，这就尴尬了。
I'm talking to 5 million people on it right now.
我这会儿正跟500万人说话呢。
How many did you guys have?
你们有多少人？
I heard she's laughing.
我听说她在笑。
Hell, start work 2019 just says, it's a rare show that can make you laugh one moment and cry your eyes at the next, you really set the standard for a television show.
天呐，“工作2019”只是说，很少有节目能让你这一秒笑出声，下一秒就泪流满面，你们确实为电视剧树立了标准。
Thanks.
谢谢。
Thank you.
谢谢你们。
That's nice.
太好了。
And Kenneth, playing Josh, I'm sure you get this question.
肯尼斯，你扮演乔osh，我相信你经常听到这个问题。
A lot of Kenneth, playing says, hey Josh, can you give me some advice?
很多演肯尼斯的人说，嘿，乔许，你能给我一些建议吗？
Is someone who wants to be an actor or share a story of how you became such a great actor?
作为一个想成为演员的人，或者分享一下你是如何成为这么优秀的演员的故事？
Well, I trained a really long time.
嗯，我训练了很长一段时间。
I did a lot of plays.
我演过很多话剧。
I went to a lot of theaters and apprenticed and interned and did non-equity companies, and then I went to grad school and worked around the clock for three straight years.
我去了很多剧院，当过学徒和实习生，在非联合剧团工作过，然后我去了研究生院，连续三年日夜不停地工作。
And then I got out of school.
然后我毕业了。
I was very fortunate to get signed by a really great agent.
我很幸运能被一个非常优秀的经纪公司签约。
And I just started working.
然后我就开始工作了。
The thing is though, like when I got out of schools, 1999, it was a different world of entertainment.
不过有一点是，当我毕业的时候，1999年，那是另一个娱乐世界。
It was a different, I mean, everything was different.
那是完全不同的，我的意思是，一切都变了。
So I think the, you know, there's people who are all, you know, a lot of people are like, the good old days were, blah, blah, blah.
所以我觉得，你知道，有些人总是，你知道，很多人会说，过去的好日子是这样的，等等。
And I'm not really one for that kind of nostalgia, but I do think that right now, I don't know that you, you know, if school is your thing, if that's where you thrive, it can be great to go to school and study a craft and be with a company of people that you're learning with.
我其实不太喜欢那种怀旧情绪，但我确实认为现在，我不知道你，你知道，如果上学是你的菜，如果你在那种环境下能茁壮成长，去学校学习一门手艺，和一群你一起学习的人组成一个剧团，这真的很棒。
But if you don't have the time, or the wherewithal, or the money to do that, take your phone and start making cool stuff.
但如果你没有时间、没有能力或没有钱去做这些，拿着你的手机，开始创作酷炫的作品吧。
Make cool movies, learn how to edit, learn how to be indispensable.
制作酷炫的电影，学会剪辑，学会让自己变得不可或缺。
You're not gonna be as good as you wanna be.
你不会一下子变得像你希望的那么好。
Ira Glass has that great quote about how when you're younger, your taste is much better than your abilities, so it's really hard.
艾拉·格拉斯有一句名言：当你年轻的时候，你的品味比你的能力好得多，所以这真的很艰难。
and you have to work until your art catches up with your taste, which is probably pretty good, even young.
你必须不断努力，直到你的艺术水平赶上你的品味，而你的品味可能相当不错，甚至在年轻时就是如此。
So you just gotta get a lot of hours under your belt and work with good people and humble yourself and ask questions and be curious and stay not cynical somehow, you know, because the business is really hard and can beat you up and spit you out.
所以你只需要积累足够的时间，和优秀的人合作，保持谦逊，多问问题，保持好奇心，无论如何不要变得愤世嫉俗，你知道的，因为这个行业真的很艰难，可能会把你打倒并无情抛弃。
But you just gotta stick with good people and ask the right questions and just be in the right place at the right time, and by that, I mean, just keep going.
但你只需要和优秀的人在一起，问正确的问题，在正确的时间出现在正确的地点，我指的是，坚持下去。
Yeah.
是的。
Craig, Brendan Yuri-Lover says, I want to know more about your writing career, any future books, you just finished this one, any future books, big fan of the book you wrote, and I want to be an author like you.
克雷格，布伦丹·尤里爱好者说，我想更多地了解你的写作生涯，有什么未来的书吗，你刚刚完成了这本，还有未来的书吗，我是你写的书的超级粉丝，我想成为像你一样的作家。
Oh, that's so nice to hear, thank you.
哦，听到这个太高兴了，谢谢。
Yeah, that was my debut novel, just came out a couple months ago, it's called That's Not How It Happened, please check it out, him and fans have been super kind, And there are definitely some little Hymium Easter eggy kind of things in there.
是的，那是我的处女作小说，几个月前刚出版，书名叫《事情不是那样的》，请去看看吧，他还有粉丝们都超级友善，里面绝对有一些《老爸老妈浪漫史》式的复活节彩蛋之类的小东西。
And I think tonally it shares a lot of the heart of Hymium and hopefully some of the humor.
而且我认为在基调上它分享了很多《老爸老妈浪漫史》的情感内核，希望也有一些幽默感。
Yeah, I want to read another one.
是的，我想再读一本。
I really do.
我真的想。
It takes a long time.
这需要很长时间。
Josh, see Josh's aforementioned comment about parenting taking a lot of time.
乔什，参见前面提到的乔什关于育儿需要很多时间的评论。
There's a lot of that happening.
有很多这样的事情正在发生。
And doing the pod and stuff.
还要做播客之类的。
I am in the gestational phase of thinking of the next book and this one has been so well received and big shout out to him and fans for that.
我正处于构思下一本书的孕育阶段，这本书反响非常好，非常感谢《老爸老妈浪漫史》的粉丝们。
So I really want to do another one.
所以我真的很想再写一本。
It's a dream.
这是一个梦想。
It isn't an amazing when you, this happens when you go on a press tour for like a huge thing you've done.
当你为一个你做过的大项目进行巡回宣传时，这种情况就会发生，难道这不神奇吗？
Right, what's next?
对吧，接下来是什么？
What do you have next?
你接下来有什么？
And it always makes your heart a little bit.
这总是让你的心稍微揪一下。
You're like, shit, I don't have it right now.
你会想，该死，我现在没有新作品。
Is this not enough?
这还不够吗？
I wrote a book, like a whole book.
我写了一本书，一整本书耶。
I know, an incredible book, by the way.
我知道，顺便说一句，这是一本不可思议的书。
I really love this book.
我真的很喜欢这本书。
I think I told Craig, even if he was my sworn enemy, I would be forced to admit he had written a great book.
我想我告诉过克雷格，即使他是我的死敌，我也得承认他写了一本好书。
It's just such- But then you'd beat me to death with the book.
这简直是——但接着你就会用这本书把我打死。
Yeah, exactly.
对，没错。
It's just such a great read.
这真的是一本太棒的读物了。
It's so page 20.
读到第20页就停不下来。
Thank you.
谢谢。
It's so funny.
太有趣了。
It's so really about something.
它真的很深刻。
It's one of those books that feels both nourishing intellectually and soulfully, but it's also hilarious and just a joy to read.
这是那种既能滋养智力又能滋养心灵的书，同时又超级搞笑，读起来简直是一种享受。
Thanks, my friend.
谢谢你，我的朋友。
I really think it was a, you really pulled something off there.
我真的觉得这是一次，你在那里确实写出了一部杰作。
Thank you, buddy.
谢谢你，老兄。
And Josh and Kobe are two of the four voices in the audiobook, so go check that out.
乔什和科比是有声书中的四个声音之中的两个，所以去听听看吧。
It is a dream, and it's inspired by my own unique journey.
这是一个梦想，它的灵感来自我独特的经历。
As a parent, it's inspired by my son, Elliot, who may or may be watching this as we speak.
作为一个父母，它的灵感来自于我的儿子埃利奥特，他现在可能正在看这个视频。
Hello, Elliot, if you are.
嗨，埃利奥特，如果你在看的话。
And I love him very much, and he inspired this book in so many ways.
我非常爱他，他在很多方面启发了这本书。
Yeah, and it did book borrows from some of my hymium life and Hollywood life, it borrows from my own family.
是的，这本书确实借用了我的一些《老爸老妈浪漫史》生活和好莱坞生活，也借用了我自己的家庭。
And I will say it's always a great thing when you can write what you know and when you can be taking things from your life and processing them into art.
我想说的是，当你能写你熟悉的事物，当你能从生活中汲取灵感并将其转化为艺术时，这总是一件美好的事。
And I think that probably also speaks to Josh's answer about being an actor.
我想这大概也印证了乔什关于做演员的回答。
It's like, just keep doing it.
就像是，只要继续做下去。
Just keep living your life and doing your thing and finding how your life filters through you into your art.
继续过你的生活，做你的事，寻找你的生活如何通过你过滤进你的艺术中。
And that is very much what happened with the book.
这正是这本书创作时的情景。
And it does take time.
这确实需要时间。
You have to get lucky.
你必须碰运气。
You have to get that right idea, but you know that feeling, right?
你必须找到那个正确的想法，但你懂那种感觉，对吧？
You know that feeling when you're kind of in it.
你知道那种你沉浸其中的感觉吗？
You're like, this is the right story, this is the right thing.
你会想，这就是正确的故事，这就是正确的东西。
And I am hoping I'm moving into that zone again with some new ideas for the next one.
我希望我能带着下一本的新点子再次进入那个状态。
But yeah, Stitchin, thank you so much for reading my book.
但是，是的，Stitchin，非常感谢你阅读我的书。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you, knew where you were sitting.
这个老头，他……爱上了你，知道你坐在哪里。
And now commercials, end of commercials, back to show.
现在是广告时间，广告结束，回到节目。
A couple of things here, someone has asked, Wait, are you guys done recording season two?
这里有几件事，有人问，等等，你们第二季录完了吗？
And yes, we are, we've just finished episode 22.
是的，我们录完了，我们刚刚完成了第22集。
We've done something borrowed, something blue.
我们做了《借来的东西，蔚蓝的东西》。
And this week, I think columns was this week's new episode, right?
这周，我想《专栏》是这周的新剧集，对吧？
Just in case people are brand new to this and they're like, where are they in season two?
以防有人是这档节目的新粉丝，他们会想，第二季进行到哪里了？
Columns, our episode of the podcast about the episode column, this dropped Monday.
《专栏》，我们关于《专栏》那一集的播客，周一上线了。
That's kind of what we're up to.
这就是我们目前的进度。
But unlike how I met your mother, which would take what, a four and a half month break, we'll be taking a much smaller break.
但与《老爸老妈浪漫史》不同，后者通常要休息四个半月左右，我们将进行短暂得多的休息。
So we'll be back with season three quite soon.
所以我们将很快带着第三季回归。
Yeah, and to be clear, it may not feel like a break at all, right?
是的，需要说明的是，这感觉可能根本不算是在休息，对吧？
Barely, right?
几乎不算，对吧？
You'll go to howwemajormother.com.
你可以访问 howwemajormother.com。
From there, you can access all of your podcast apps, Apple Podcasts and Spotify and Amazon and a few others.
从那里，你可以访问你所有的播客应用，苹果播客、Spotify、亚马逊以及其他一些平台。
Few other things, just so everyone knows in the questions here, we are not going to say things that you ask us to say.
还有几件事，为了让提问环节的每个人都知道，我们不会说你们要求我们说的话。
It's lovely that you want us to say certain things, but if you'd like to just save yourself some time on the typing, it's probably- All right, I'll sing love you on Rose.
很高兴你们想让我们说某些话，但如果你想节省一点打字的时间，可能——好吧，我会唱《爱你直到天荒地老》。
Not other than that.
除此之外没有别的了。
If you give us some of the words that Robin had to say on the news, maybe we'll save those.
如果你给我们提供一些罗宾在新闻里说过的话，也许我们会留着。
Yes, and possibly the I'm of naughty girl or whatever that was, I don't remember, anyway.
是的，可能还有那个“我是个淘气的女孩”或者诸如此类的话，我不记得了，总之。
All right, but send us down and we'll save those.
好吧，但请发给我们，我们会保存那些。
So people have asked us before, and actually haven't talked about where the idea came from.
所以以前有人问过我们，其实我们还没讨论过这个创意是从哪里来的。
M.
M。
嗯。
Frata 07 says, Craig, how did you or Carter come up with having everyone's significant other be in the show?
Frata 07说，克雷格，你或卡特是怎么想到让每个人的另一半都在剧里出演的？
I love the cameos, such a cool idea.
我很喜欢这些客串，太酷的主意了。
Yeah, it always makes me happy.
是的，这总是让我很高兴。
We just talked about something brought out something blue and that in those two, one of those two, I guess in the second, again, the second last episode of season, do you see Neil and David Birka, Neil's then partner and now husband?
我们刚才谈到了一个东西，引出了一些蓝色的东西，在那种情况下，在这两个角色中，在其中一个里面，我猜在第二，再次是倒数第二集里，你们看到尼尔和大卫·伯卡了吗，尼尔当时的伴侣、现在的丈夫？
And it's cool, they're like, there they are in a scene together, and David is so funny and they're seeing each other.
太酷了，他们就像是，他们一起出现在一个镜头里，大卫太逗了，他们俩在看对方。
And they're like, yeah.
然后他们就，对。
They're just me, they go, hey, scooter, what's up?
他们简直就是我，他们说，嘿，斯库特，最近怎么样？
And they're, they're, they were really funny together in that scene and David's super funny.
然后他们，他们，他们在那个镜头里一起配合得非常搞笑，大卫超级逗。
The answer to the question is everyone was so funny.
这个问题的答案就是每个人都太搞笑了。
David's hilarious as scooter.
大卫演的斯库特简直绝了。
Alexis Dennasoff, like Carter and I, and my wife Rebecca got Carter and I into Buffy and Angel.
阿历克丝·德纳索夫，就像卡特和我，还有我的妻子丽贝卡，让卡特和我迷上了《吸血鬼巴菲》和《天使》 。
And Alexis Dennasoff is so great on Angel.
而阿历克丝·德纳索夫在《天使》里表现得太棒了。
Anyone who has watched Angel, he was Wesley on Angel.
任何看过《天使》的人都知道，他在《天使》里饰演韦斯利。
And he was like, absolutely riveting on that show.
他在那部剧里简直是太吸引人了。
He's British accented on that show.
他在那部剧里带着英国口音。
And he's really funny at first, a really silly, funny character, like the comic relief, and then goes to a whole other place through the series.
他一开始非常搞笑，是一个非常傻气、滑稽的角色，就像喜剧担当一样，然后随着剧情的发展，走向了完全不同的方向。
It becomes almost like a romantic lead you're rooting for.
他变得几乎就像一个你为之加油的浪漫男主角。
He's great.
他太棒了。
And so funny, Sandy Rivers.
还有超级搞笑的桑迪·里弗斯。
So that's the thing, he has those comedy chops.
所以这就是重点，他很有喜剧天赋。
And people sort of forgot at the end of Angel, his character became very serious and dark.
人们在《天使》大结局时有点忘了，他的角色变得非常严肃和黑暗。
And people kind of forgot in the industry, I think that he began as a very funny character at the beginning of Angel.
我认为业内的人都有点忘了，他在《天使》刚开始时其实是个非常搞笑的角色。
So then, and Carter and I remember that, and we're like, Alexis is hilarious, we know it for a fact, because we saw it in the early seasons of Angel.
所以，然后，卡特和我都记得，我们在想，阿历克丝太逗了，我们对此心知肚明，因为我们在《天使》的前几季里都看到了。
So that's why we cast him as Sandy Rivers.
所以这就是我们选他演桑迪·里弗斯的原因。
And Taryn Gillum, I mean, he went on to be on SNL after guesting on our show.
还有塔伦·吉勒姆，我的意思是，他在客串了我们的节目后，后来去了《周六夜现场》。
He's hilarious, and this was not us doing favors for significant artists.
他太逗了，这可不是我们在卖人情给重要的艺术家。
We actually were funny, but we love them all.
我们其实很有趣，但我们真的很爱他们所有人。
It is amazing though that like, it was just dumb luck that everyone was like partnered with hilarious people.
不过真是太神奇了，纯粹是走了狗屎运，每个人都和超级搞笑的人结为了伴侣。
like you could have looked at as like spousal favors, but they were like absolutely made the show better.
虽然你可能会觉得这是出于夫妻情面，但他们绝对让这部剧变得更好了。
Like bookable actor, yeah, they would come in, they would have come in and got those parts.
就像一个有票房号召力的演员，是的，他们会来，他们本就会来并拿下那些角色。
And we instead we just got to say to them like, hey, would you do this and be like, yeah, I'm hanging out anyway.
而我们呢，我们只是有机会对他们说，嘿，你愿意做这个吗，然后他们就会说，行啊，反正我也闲着。
My way thanks on the show, I'm sitting here.
顺便在剧里露个脸，我正坐在这儿呢。
Yeah.
对。
Okay, we've got a very special audience member.
好吧，我们有一位非常特别的观众。
I mean, all our audience members are special, our fans are special, But this one, her name is Angela Kinsey.
我是说，我们所有的观众都很特别，我们的粉丝都很特别，但这位，她叫安吉拉·金西。
She comes from at Angela Kinsey.
她来自@Angela Kinsey。
Angela, of course, for everyone.
对每个人来说，安吉拉，当然了。
It's bringing people.
正在把大家聚在一起。
Who knows, doesn't know, is, of course, from the office and hosts, co-host, which Anna Fisher, the amazing office ladies podcast.
谁知道、谁不知道，当然是出自《办公室》并主持、共同主持了安娜·费舍尔那个了不起的《办公室女士》播客。
And we are part of their network.
我们是他们网络的一部分。
And Angela is listening and watching as we speak.
此时此刻，安吉拉正在收听和观看我们的节目。
Hi Angela.
嗨，安吉拉。
And she says, Craig, was there a supporting character that you loved writing a laugh line for?
她说，克雷格，有没有哪个配角是你特别喜欢为他写搞笑台词的？
Like in the office, we get excited if we got the comedy button in a scene.
就像在《办公室》里一样，如果我们在一个场景里得到了喜剧包袱，我们就会很兴奋。
So for you, we're like, oh, I can't wait to get, this character's gonna get a line and gonna knock it out of the park.
所以对你来说，我们会觉得，哦，我等不及要写了，这个角色会有一句台词，而且一定会大获成功。
Are we saying a main cast or is this larger?
我们说的是主要演员还是范围更广？
It sounds like she's got a supporting character.
听起来她说的是个配角。
So maybe a waitress, maybe a bartender, you know, something like that.
所以可能是个女服务员，可能是个调酒师，你知道，诸如此类的。
I think Ranjit pops right into my head immediately.
我想兰吉特立刻就跳进我的脑海里了。
Josh, you know what I mean?
乔什，你知道我的意思吗？
Because you could write just Ranjit, turn around and say, hello!
因为你只需要写兰吉特转过身来说，你好！
And like Marshall Manesh, that actor which is so funny and charismatic.
就像马歇尔·马内什那个演员，太逗了，太有魅力了。
And if hello became a joke for him.
如果“你好”成了他的一个梗的话。
Yeah, which is interesting.
对，这很有趣。
And it got to feeling like the cast, the characters, and the audience were never not delighted when Ranjit would come by.
而且感觉演员阵容、角色和观众，只要兰吉特出现，就从来没有不高兴的。
Yeah, it was a hold for applause from an audience that was not there at that level.
是的，这就好比是在向一个并不在现场的观众强行索要掌声。
I also think going through the first two seasons, you forget how much steward.
我也觉得，回顾前两季时，你都会忘记斯图尔特占了多大分量。
Matt Boren.
马特·博伦。
Matt Boren is a round and so funny.
马特·博伦无处不在，而且非常搞笑。
And also Joe Manganello, like.
还有乔·曼根尼罗，比如。
Joe Manganello.
乔·曼根尼罗。
He like really pops up in such a funny way throughout those first yeah And then those guys are together as two of the guys on the bachelor party in those last couple of episodes of season two And like Matt and Joe could be like their own like road trip movie.
他在前几季中确实以一种非常搞笑的方式频频亮相，对，然后这两人在第二季最后几集的单身派对上作为其中两个哥们聚在了一起，马特和乔简直可以拍一部他们自己的公路旅行电影。
I would watch a movie That's just the two of them.
我会看一部完全是他们俩的电影。
Matt is just like he plays this character's doing with this is long suffering He's just like married to this really intense woman.
马特就像是——他扮演的这个角色正在经历这一切，饱受折磨，他只是娶了这个非常强势的女人。
It's clearly very miserable and Joe Meganello looks like Thor and He doesn't have the miserable he doesn't know how to suffer in that way.
显然过得很悲惨，而乔·曼根尼罗看起来像雷神索尔，他可没有那种悲惨，他不懂该怎么那样去受苦。
And he was, but of course on the show, he played Brad who did have his heart broken and essentially kind of dated Marshall for a little while on an episode.
但他，当然在这部剧里，他扮演了布拉德，他的心确实碎了，在某一集中基本上算是和马歇尔约会了一小段时间。
And that, he was so funny because he talked on the Abreaves, you know, going through a bit of a depression.
而且那段，他太逗了，因为他在阿布里夫斯讲话，你知道的，正在经历一点抑郁。
And it's the, this ex-Benny is Redonk when they're on their brunch date.
这就是，当他们吃早午餐时，前本尼的说法简直太荒谬了。
It's just like when you could find a Sanzer Angeles question when you could find a character that developed an immediate, like, really recognizable way of speaking It was completely unlike everybody else on the show.
这就像是，当你能找到一个像桑兹·安杰莱斯的提问那样，能够塑造出一个具有即时、极具辨识度的说话方式的角色时，它完全不同于剧中的所有人。
That's a joy.
这真是一件令人高兴的事。
That's a joy when you get that.
当你得到这个时，这真是一件令人高兴的事。
Joe was definitely like that way as Brad on the show.
乔在剧里演布拉德时绝对就是这样的。
George Graham wonders which character would be the worst or best and or best podcast host?
乔治·格雷厄姆想知道哪个角色会是最差的或最好的，或者既是最好又是最差的播客主持人？
Wait, this is.
等等，这个是。
Well, Josh Ramner, I think.
嗯，我想是乔什·拉姆纳。
Well, I hope that I would be the best of the character, though, but the character.
好吧，我希望自己能成为最好的角色，不过就角色而言。
I think Ted was a podcaster before Dr. X, Dr. X.
我想泰德在X博士之前就是一个播客了，X博士。
He's an absolute trailblazer.
他是绝对的开拓者。
That's the answer.
这就是答案。
What's a trailblazer?
什么是开拓者？
Ted had a real history in radio.
泰德在广播界有着真正的历史。
Yes, and never owned up to being Dr. X, even though everyone knew this was his college radio show that aired at midnight, and he was like, he had the alias, and he was, I'm telling you the truth.
是的，而且从来不承认自己就是X博士，尽管大家都知道这是他在午夜播出的大学广播节目，而且他就像是，他用了化名，而且他当时的态度是，我告诉你们的是实话。
So I can't let him let my name get out there, because of the word.
所以我不能让我的名字传出去，因为这个词。
He thought he was like a folk hero, right?
他觉得自己就像个民间英雄，对吧？
Yeah, it was a folk hero.
对，就是一个民间英雄。
I'm just Dr. Rex.
我只是X博士。
I'm only here for the truth.
我来这里只是为了真相。
I'm not here to aggrandize myself.
我不是来自我标榜的。
And it was really, he had a sort of dark, webby podcast vibe before the internet existed.
而且真的很搞笑，在互联网存在之前，他就有一种黑暗、网络风格的播客氛围。
Yeah.
是的。
So definitely Ted is Dr. Rex is the podcast.
所以泰德即是X博士，绝对的播客。
And maybe we should consider doing that, Josh.
也许我们应该考虑做那个，乔什。
What do you want to just, we'll do a podcast that's that?
你想不想直接，我们就做一个那样的播客？
There's kind of like the seeds of like Robin would have gotten a little hooked by QAnon.
这里有点像罗宾会被QAnon（匿名者Q）稍微迷住的苗头。
Like not fully, but a little, She would have gotten a little stacked up in the gears of it for a while.
不是完全陷进去，但有点儿，她有一段时间会被卷入其中无法自拔。
There could have been an event.
本来可以安排这样一个情节的。
Until people talked her down.
直到大家把她劝回来。
I thought you were going to say Robin would be a good podcast host because she's a newscaster, but instead you went to QAnon.
我还以为你要说罗宾会是个好的播客主持人，因为她是新闻主播，结果你却扯到了QAnon。
So I don't know, I don't know what to say.
所以我不知道，我不知道该说什么好。
Maybe she'd be like Carrie Lake.
也许她会像凯莉·莱克一样。
Like she'd like run for office in some like hard right campaign.
就像她会参加某个极右翼竞选去竞选公职一样。
Spin off, okay.
衍生剧，好吧。
We're writing this.
我们在写这个。
Where is she in 2026?
到2026年她会在哪里？
Brian underscored Nara does also suggest that Sandy Rivers would be the best and worst podcast host.
布莱恩强调，娜拉也暗示桑迪·里弗斯会是最棒也是最糟糕的播客主持人。
Oh, yes.
哦，是的。
That's a good one.
这个不错。
Yes, I think there's definitely some versions of Sandy Rivers hosting podcasts.
对，我觉得绝对有些版本的桑迪·里弗斯在主持播客。
And also the bros that Marshall worked with, Marshall with his like sweet-hearted environmental law background goes to work at this horrible corporation that Barney works for.
还有马歇尔合作过的那些兄弟们，马歇尔带着他那种心地善良的环境法背景，去巴尼工作的那个可怕的公司上班。
Those bros like Billson and Blauman, I think were their names.
那些兄弟，像比尔森和布劳曼，我想他们叫这名字。
Those guys definitely have a problematic podcast of some kind.
那家伙们绝对会弄出一个有争议的某种播客。
Billson and Blauman were two of my favorite names you guys came up with.
比尔森和布劳曼是我最喜欢的你们想出来的两个名字。
I think Carl MacLaren, our assistant namesake of McLaren's bar, he may have come up with both of those names.
我想卡尔·麦克拉伦，我们麦克拉伦酒吧的助理同名人，他可能想出了这两个名字。
Carl was great at inventing weird fake names that sound like middle managers with short sleeve buttoned down shirts and ties.
卡尔很擅长发明一些古怪的假名字，听起来就像穿着短袖扣领衬衫和系着领带的中层管理人员。
with like short sleeve button down shirts and ties.
穿着短袖扣领衬衫和领带。
Those are an enble omen.
这些都是好兆头。
Yeah.
对。
And I think finally here, Ashley Chon Sec, who I think maybe has asked some questions from us before I think so, says that I'm saying final one, but if there's more good questions, just keep them coming here.
我想最后是阿什利·琼·塞克，我想她以前可能问过我们一些问题，我想是的，她说这是最后一个问题，不过如果还有好问题，尽管发过来。
We'll see.
我们到时候看。
But asks a lovely question, besides family and friends and the necessities, what is one random thing you absolutely could not live without.
但她问了一个可爱的问题：除了家人、朋友和生活必需品之外，绝对不能没有的一件随机事物是什么？
Can I hit pause for one second and just say also, the reason that Angela is messaging us is because Angela and Jenna were kind enough to invite us into the OLN world.
我能暂停一下说个事吗？安吉拉给我们发消息是因为安吉拉和珍娜好心邀请我们进入OLN的世界。
This is for the new, the people finding this for the first time.
这是对新听众、第一次发现这个节目的人说的。
We are part of the Office Ladies Network now.
我们现在是“办公室女士网络”（Office Ladies Network）的一部分了。
I think we didn't explain that at all when Angela was ready to get some questions.
安吉拉准备收问题时，我们好像完全没解释这个。
I said that a little bit.
我稍微提了一下。
Okay, okay.
好吧，好吧。
But we're very lucky to be part of the Office Ladies Network.
但我们非常幸运能成为“办公室女士网络”的一部分。
You can find us over by the Empire.
你可以在他们建立的帝国那边找到我们。
they're building, they do it the best, they were definitely walking in their footsteps, doing a rewatch pod, the office ladies are amazing, so we were very grateful to them, and we're happy to be part of their team.
他们做得最好，他们走过的路绝对是我们的榜样，做重温播客，“办公室女士”太棒了，所以我们非常感激他们，也很高兴能加入他们的团队。
Yes.
是的。
All true.
千真万确。
So as I was thinking back, what do you know about it?
所以我回想了一下，你对此有什么了解？
So, yeah, the office ladies.
所以，对，办公室女士。
Angela and Jenna, we can't leave it out as the answer.
安吉拉和珍娜，我们不能把她们排除在答案之外。
Besides family, friends, Angela and Jenna, and the other necessities of life, what is one random thing?
除了家人、朋友、安吉拉和珍娜以及生活的其他必需品，还有什么随机的东西吗？
What is one thing that you absolutely cannot live without?
有什么东西是你绝对不能没有的？
How technically are we gonna get here?
我们要聊到多深的技术层面？
Josh, do you have anything?
乔什，你有什么吗？
This is a tough question.
这是一个艰难的问题。
Well, I don't think I should answer.
嗯，我觉得我不该回答。
Like if I should look for like a soul answer or just like a material fact kind of answer.
我是该寻找一个灵魂层面的答案，还是仅仅是一个物质层面的答案。
What would you take with you other than your child and your house is on fire?
如果家里着火了，除了你的孩子，你会带走什么？
Yeah, I would take a guitar.
对，我会带一把吉他。
Like I would take my guild guitar.
比如我会带我的吉尔德吉他。
Yeah.
对。
I have the same answer.
我的答案一样。
I literally, that's exactly what popped into my head when I was outside of it.
我 literalmente（字面意思），这正是我脑子里闪过的第一个念头。
I think music, I couldn't live without music.
我觉得是音乐，我不能没有音乐。
It's, music brought me everything.
音乐带给我一切。
Like music, like music is how, doing, playing music with Carter in college is how we became friends and created how much mother.
就像音乐，在大学里和卡特一起玩音乐是我们成为朋友并创造《老爸老妈浪漫史》的方式。
So if you take it all the way back, I feel like how much mother came out of music.
所以如果你追根溯源，我觉得《老爸老妈浪漫史》就是从音乐中诞生的。
And every, so many of the good things in my life came out of music.
我生命中很多美好的事物都源于音乐。
Playing in bands in college, like I met my wife and my son Elliot is like this little musical being.
在大学里组乐队，我遇到了我的妻子，我的儿子埃利奥特就像个小音乐精灵。
my daughter Celia just took up the saxophone.
我的女儿西莉亚刚刚开始学萨克斯。
And has this really cool two-tone saxophone like, it's because of Lisa Simpson.
她有一个很酷的双色萨克斯，因为丽莎·辛普森。
Cause she loves the Simpson so much, she's like, I'm gonna play that instrument like Lisa.
因为她太喜欢《辛普森一家》了，她说：“我要像丽莎那样演奏那个乐器。”
And we were like, we're gonna buy her a saxophone cause she likes Lisa, what if she doesn't stick with it?
我们当时想，我们要给她买个萨克斯因为她喜欢丽莎，万一她三分钟热度呢？
She loves it, she's totally crushing it and sticking with it.
她超爱，她完全驾驭住了并且坚持了下来。
It's not easy.
这可不容易。
Yeah, it's a tough, yeah, she takes the last number of week and she's like really good, she's into recital.
对，挺难的，她每周上课，吹得真好，她还要去参加独奏会。
And Elliot is playing drums and keyboards I'm like singing in his family players.
埃利奥特在打鼓和弹键盘，我在他家人的乐队里唱歌。
It is, we're trying to become the Vontraps.
我们在试图成为冯·特拉普一家（《音乐之声》中的家庭）。
And it's that part of life is, I wouldn't want to live in a world without that.
生活中的那部分，我不希望在一个没有音乐的世界里生活。
You know, it's like that has been such a part of my life.
你知道，那是我的生命中如此重要的一部分。
And yeah, that's what I, that's a necessity.
所以，这就是我，这是必需品。
I have a teddy bear.
我有一个泰迪熊。
That's the teddy bear would always go first.
泰迪熊肯定是首当其冲的。
I've gotten ready to take with me.
我已经准备好带走它了。
Barry.
巴里。
Does this go back to childhood?
这可以追溯到童年吗？
Is this like the original teddy bear?
这是最初那个泰迪熊吗？
No, or you still have this right now.
不是，你现在还留着它。
I still have it right now.
我到现在还留着。
Absolutely go get it on Instagram live.
绝对可以在Instagram直播上拿出来。
That's too far away.
那太远了。
It's too far Way next time next time Just a quick shout out to Marco 1503 who said I got to be an extra on the show.
太远了，下次吧，下次。顺便向Marco 1503打个招呼，他说他成了节目里的群演。太棒了，酷。
It was great cool Yeah, all right, so Let's see.
好的，那么，让我们看看。
Yeah, I think I think that's probably gonna be our our Instagram live for today We'll just say a few quick things one is that yes, yes, please please there is a podcast Please tell four or five of your hymium-loving friends.
对，我想这大概就是我们今天的Instagram直播了，我们简单说几点，一是，求求你们，真的，有一个播客，请告诉四五个喜欢《老爸老妈浪漫史》的朋友。
There's also a great Facebook group.
还有一个很棒的Facebook群组。
It's called Major Fans.
叫做Major Fans。
Major Fans.
Major Fans。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Go over to them.
去加入他们吧。
It's like a private group, so you'll go in.
这是一个私密群组，所以你需要申请加入。
It's a lovely community of people talking about all this.
这是一个讨论所有这些内容的可爱社群。
I post things a lot there.
我在那里发很多东西。
I answer people's questions.
我回答大家的问题。
I ask four people's questions to ask of Josh and Craig.
我收集大家的问题去问乔什和克雷格。
Check that out.
去看看吧。
These These Instagram lives, the audio will appear, eventually, in the podcast, Bead.
这些Instagram直播的音频最终会出现在播客节目中。
And again, just for you here, we're not really going to tell you too much.
再次声明，在这里我们不会透露太多。
We're just going to say that we did just record something very special.
我们只想说，我们刚刚录制了一些非常特别的内容。
And you're all going to get to not just- Did I do that?
你们不仅能——是我干的吗？
We'll explain it later.
我们以后再解释。
Sorry.
抱歉。
That was right.
那是对的。
And you are all going to get to not just hear it, but see it on YouTube in a couple of weeks.
你们不仅能在几周后听到它，还能在YouTube上看到它。
Yeah.
对。
one more thing like if you love how I met your mother and you love it in a I don't know like if it's just a comfort show or you like to have it on the background that's cool but there's a whole kind of thing we're doing like it almost feels like Craig and I are both students and professors in a college course dedicated to how I met your mother like we are really peeling back the layers of the themes of I think if you're interested in telling stories and hearing from like like a master storyteller, like Craig, who has such deep insights into what they were doing and how they were thinking about it and what they had planned and what was an accident and all kinds of stuff.
还有一件事，如果你爱《老爸老妈浪漫史》，而且你喜欢把它当成一部——我不知道，比如一部解压剧，或者喜欢把它当背景音播放，那很酷，但我们正在做一件很全面的事，感觉克雷格和我既是一门专门研究《老爸老妈浪漫史》的大学课程的学生又是教授，我们真的在层层剥茧地剖析其中的主题。我想如果你对讲故事感兴趣，想听听像克雷格这样的大师讲故事，他对他们在做什么、他们是怎么想的、他们有什么计划、什么是偶然发生的等等有着如此深刻的见解。
So if you want to know just how this thing got made and what was asked of us as actors and how we collaborated with the writers and the director and everyone, it's a really like 360 view of a show that a lot of people love and that we happen to be world's leading experts on.
所以如果你想知道这部剧是怎么拍出来的，作为演员我们被要求做些什么，以及我们是如何与编剧、导演和所有人合作的，这真的是一个全方位的视角，展现了一部很多人喜爱、而碰巧我们是世界顶尖专家的剧集。
We were there, we know what happened, we know what didn't happen, we know what it took to make it.
我们就在现场，我们知道发生了什么，我们知道什么没发生，我们知道把它拍出来需要付出什么。
We have different insight now that we're older and we're a couple years down the line from it.
随着我们年龄增长，以及事情过去了好几年，我们现在有了不同的见解。
But to me, I'm just learning so much about this show we made.
但对我和说，关于我们制作的这部剧，我正在学到非常多的东西。
Like I'm learning things every week, like from Craig.
就像我每周都在从克雷格那里学到东西一样。
If you love the show and you want to go deeper and you know my mother-in-law listens and she's never even seen an episode of how I do mother I don't think she's planning on watching it she just likes listening to it so even if you don't have any interest in the show it's still apparently a great show to listen to so that's just a little just a deeper apply for the podcast How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
如果你喜欢这部剧，想要深入了解，而且你知道我的岳母会听，尽管她甚至没看过一集《老爸老妈浪漫史》，我觉得她也不打算看，她只是喜欢听这个节目——所以，即使你对这部剧完全不感兴趣，显然它依然是一个非常棒的播客节目。这就是对播客《老爸老妈浪漫史是如何拍成的》的更深入介绍。该节目由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人，由Office Ladies网络和Audyssey公司呈现和发行。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集的执行制片人还有詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
本节目由我亚历克·莱夫制作和剪辑，我们的联合制作人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point2Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是Point2Blue工作室的亚历克斯·里夫斯。
Our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，也就是Z世代大师，是艾米莉·布隆伯格。
Artwork by John Morrow.
封面艺术由约翰·莫罗创作。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或你选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这确实对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是《纽约市》，由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳创作，克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基提供额外音乐。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢罗拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajormother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
访问HowWeMajormother.com了解更多信息，并点击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你们的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
请在Substack上订阅乔什·拉德纳的时事通讯，并在JoshRadner.com上查看他的音乐以及其他一切内容。
After Craig Thomas' debut novel, that's not how it happened, wherever books are sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasWriter.com.
购买克雷格·托马斯的首部小说《事情不是这样的》（各大图书均有销售），并在CraigThomasWriter.com上查看他发表的其他作品。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
你也可以订阅我自己的《已故父亲协会》，同样在Substack上。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解更多关于如何做出贡献的信息——本节目旨在为先天性小儿心脏病研究筹集资金的持续活动——请查看我们网站顶部的“做出贡献”标签。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，会跳舞的。